[Musik]
mit dem jugendliche 2021 war die flut
das war
alles das alles weg
wir haben nicht viel retten können
eigentlich
dann fehlt auch die komplette wand in
der hatte herr werkstatt um alles so zu
stellen als zwecke schwung ist kaputt
und josefa retten können die reformen
werden
mehr wenn wir nicht finden
[Musik]
ich habe am anfang versucht die
haushalte zu machen das hat gar nichts
gebracht
mir stand das wasser hüfthoch ich hab
ihn nicht gesehen wo ich lange was da
schwimmen der wohnung hat sich auch
höchst ich bin gefallen sachen gibt's
hingegen nicht gestorben ich war das
irgendwie
kompletten beiden über 40 blaue flecken
und bürger gäste und das tut auch
ordentlich weh aber ich habe es jetzt
alles gekühlt wir haben noch versucht
mülltonnen vor der tür zu verteilen dass
nicht so viel wasser
dagegen kann man nichts
falsch stark geregnet und dann ist halt
die arbeiten zum ort am frühen abend
stark und schnell angestiegen
nach von
10-15 minuten war das wasser schon drin
dann bin ich auch gar nicht mehr ins
haus rein gekommen weil bei uns der hof
geht halt nach unten und dass es dann
halt als treibgut hat sich gerungen ich
will nicht mehr reingekommen
[Musik]
weil zeichen in sachen
nichts mehr drin
das wasser stand
[Musik]
und wieder kaufen
am 25
ich habe es noch geschafft
kinder von draußen zu finden
die fotos die sind ja noch besser kennen
da draußen dazu finden habe ich es
schwer ändern
wir haben auf seinen stuhl beim nachbarn
im keller
stade die meisten bilder glaube ich auch
nicht mehr aus
wir wollten heute erfahren
man kann das auch gar nicht fassen weil
das alles viel zu schnell ging
man auch nicht damit gerechnet hatte
dass es so schlimm hätte sein können man
wusste dass es viel regnen wird alles so
schnell und es war wirklich eine
überforderung dafür konnte man gar nicht
nachkommt ist nicht richtig begleitet
unser kater den haben wir noch mit noch
ungewohnt aber man kann die teams ich
mein vater wollte im garten holen da
stand auch mal mauer die mauer ist
eingebrochen als hätte holen wollte die
kaninchen
sind jetzt leider mit weggeschlossen die
werden wir nicht finden
am nächsten morgen
vormittags ist ja meine mutter zu
bekommen hat mich abgeholt und dann
haben wir erstmals sind wir durch den
garten
durch die kaputte glas von da ins haus
gekommen und haben alle sachen gefallen
zurzeit wohnen hier war meinen
großeltern zehn kilometer entfernt von
schuld und
wir wohnen jetzt in der wohnung über den
schön hier zu sein dass ich habe auch
meine eigenes zimmer und alles aber ich
wäre glaube ich lieber doch inzwischen
wieder zu hause und das weil man sich
schon ziemlich sehr auch wenn es sehr
schön hier ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
man hat wirklich an jeder ecke gemerkt
dass man hilfe bekommen hat und es waren
natürlich auch alles super freundlich
ich habe lange nicht mehr so viel mit
meinen nachbarn gesprochen und noch mit
ganz vielen anderen leuten aus dem dorf
die man eigentlich total gut kennt dass
sport einsam
[Musik]
das dauert bis man wirklich auch
verinnerlicht wirklich maxi los
man ist auch nicht alleine es gibt allen
leuten eigentlich so die betroffen sind
und das ist dann auch wirklich hilfreich
dass man auf andere leute die ein dass
das dann gebt sehr gut vorstellen könne
zwei wochen nach der flut
natürlich möchte ich wieder einmal zu
hause zurück ziehen das ist mir sehr
wichtig hülle ich möchte ich dann auch
dass meine freunde oder generell
jeden der da wohnt und der auch
betroffenen dass sie wieder alles normal
da zurückziehen können und ich wünsche
mir auch wirklich dieses grün wie dabei
wir hatten dort wo sehr viele pflanzen
gärtner
gewachsen sind das hat man schon
ziemlich gemerkt dass das alles zielt
das ist mein zuhause das macht es auch
immer sein aber es wird auch wieder
schwer verändern herum zu laufen weil es
einfach nicht so ist wie früher
auch wenn man zum beispiel wirklich
unten geht um nicht sicher ist wo ich
jetzt in welcher straße reingehen muss
weil man es nicht mehr gut erkennen
können weil die häuser wachsen aber
natürlich auch wirklich die menschen die
wegziehen weil wir auch einige bekannte
haben die wegziehen werden und dem 4
kontakt toppen natürlich hat man halt
angst das ist alles nur wieder passieren
könnte war es natürlich auch um einiges
einfacher sich einfach woanders neue
wohnungen dein neues haus zu rufen
sechs wochen sind seit der flut a gang
ich kann jetzt endlich wieder in die
schule gehen und einerseits ist es
natürlich schule motivation ist relativ
aber ich freue mich öffentlich weil es
auch wieder ganz normal ist das
normalität ist echt schön jetzt erst mal
zusammen kreis mit botschaften wie man
hat jetzt auch gefragt wie ich heute
morgen entgegen zu kommen
musste natürlich auch dann alles
überprüft werden wie das jetzt auch mit
den adressen wird dann hat man schon mal
darüber gesprochen warum sie nicht
unterdrückt haben eben noch ein bisschen
unterhalten
wenn ich aber nach hause war allein
schon die busfahrt linie das ist alles
anders selbst
ich finde ich schon dass es alles sehr
schnell weitergehen dort bin ich auch
glücklich
schon immer die fortschritte
großen ganzen wollen wir dann
mitarbeiter hier sehen wir auch hinten
dann auf unsere politische küche also
können wir eigentlich wieder
oben weil dann kein wirksamer ist auch
sehr gut ist wenn meine eltern und der
kater in die nacht ihr auch hier oben
war
[Musik]
die haben wir gleich ein halbes jahr
bevor die flut war unten wo jetzt die
küche kirche ist stand das ja allein
drin ich habe ein halbes jahr vor der
flut reichte mir das dann geholt und das
muss mein fahrrad fahren dieses teil
das hier ist immer noch mein zuhause und
ich kann mir auch gar nicht vorstellen
hier wegzuziehen
generell aus dem ort um auch hier aus
dem haus
also ich mag auto sie in dem buch hab
ick hab mit dem händewaschen oder soll
ich meinen klar ancona hatte ich von uns
allen hier gehen bisschen geärgert aber
irgendwie habe ich immer ein ganz großes
problem damit bringt sowieso nichts mit
genetik seitdem aber insbesondere an den
händen und
das finde ich dann immer ganz ganz
schlimm sind wenn ich jetzt nicht
wirklich was ich mache das immer
staubige und allein diesen staub kann
ich nicht mehr abmahnungen
[Musik]
ein stückchen sketche und sie werden es
bedenklich dass wir unser
jugendfeuerwehr zählt tage 2009 10
hatten das davon denn unsere zelte aus
standen und jetzt da vorne einfach mal
betreten werden es ist schon schwer
gerade wenn man bedenkt dass kinder oft
gefehlt war
schon sehr anders und
gewöhnungsbedürftig auf jeden fall
[Musik]
einen tag vor weihnachten
wir sind definitiv die ersten die sagen
können dass sie so wieder nach hause
können zumal auch wirklich zu den leuten
wenn nicht sogar die leute sind die am
weitesten sind bei dem mars und dann
sage ich jetzt nur also ich würde schon
sein dass meine eltern da am meisten
gemacht haben ganz dollar auf jeden fall
mein papa auch die ich dann halt auch
schon mal wieder ich dann nachmittags er
nach der schule zum oper gefallen bin
anstatt hier runter aber also regelmäßig
mit
ganze familie hat die letzten wochen
immer an dem wochenende habe ich
eigentlich immer fordern ab sollte ich
keine zeit habe gerade weil es jetzt so
kurz davor dass sie wieder einzeln und
dann freut es mich dass
ich hab halt wieder hat ein eigenes
zimmer aber das hier ist sehr viel
größeren ich habe definitiv überhaupt
frei das hat mich schon ziemlich auch
gestört irgendwas ich nicht wirklich
viel privatsphäre für mich hatte
aber gibt's
aber das kann ich jetzt mal wieder
[Musik]
eigentlich bringen möge die wir auf
jeden fall haben der kommt wieder ins
zimmer
schneckenburger
tragen sagt gearbeitet auch am
wochenende am sonntag auch sozusagen
zwei helfer eingestellt weil den
einlassen kann man das alles gar nicht
drehen
und
natürlich auch
die
privaten uns wahnsinnig auch ganz viele
von kentucky und natürlich auch immer
welche die immer wieder und kommen
auch wenn das andere aber ganz okay aber
es ist nicht zu hause zuhauses hier
und man will natürlich auf so schnell
wie möglich wieder zurück wenn das
gerade weihnachten auch unschöne anders
um dann wieder zu sein zu können
[Musik]
fehlen von dem kindlichen ist jetzt eher
weg also dadurch dass jetzt auch mal
verantwortung übernehmen muss irgendwas
was macht oder wenn sie rat war das hier
ist doch wohin führt also dazu sachen
klar machen ein selbstbewusster und man
weiß dann halt eben ich kann das und das
gibt dem ganzen natürlich immer schon
das 1 1 geglückt fahrrad klar
[Musik]
falscher weise nach der gelernte
salzburg sein vater
habe ihm ein paar anfragen von service
und macht dann hat das immer so weit so
ziemlich alle gefahren haben und nicht
so schwer
[Musik]
das sind gespendeter spiele also schon
mal benutzt aber die reichen ja auch mal
aus
ich bin schon sehr sehr erleichtert wir
zu hause zu sein und das macht auch
meinen alltag um einiges leichter
das erste mal wieder am tisch zu sitzen
man ja wohl noch bekommen habe weil die
flut die hatten auch alles war schon
irgendwie stolz ist ein schönes gefühl
dass es dann auch wieder zu hause es ist
halt ist wieder im ist sondern
eigentlich die nation hat
das sind kleine ich das gleiche aber ich
wirklich sehr
ein jahr nach der cenote
[Musik]
irgendwann mal wieder schön sagen auch
wenn es ein freitag dauern wird
[Musik]
sehr schön seine funktion und abhängig
davon sind hell anderen gemüsen und sehr
wachsam
durch gemacht und trotzdem setzen wir
jetzt alle hier und so glücklicher
zufrieden und es gibt eigentlich schon
das gefühl von innerlicher stärke und
das schaffen kann natürlich merken auch
dass man körperlich durch die aber ich
muss geld angelegt hat
[Musik]